[Music]
would you guys use these
toilets public toilets whoa
you could see people squatting in them
you see right through them
why would they do that i'm very confused
look at that it's
so you're on your best behavior maybe
wait she hasn't she's gonna [ __ ] through
her dress
yeah pretty much it's it's an invisible
toilet but in a not invisible clothes
why is it acrylic all over
all right so these are the new toilets
being installed in 17
locations across shibuya and tokyo ah
in japan japan why is it so luxurious
and so the reason why they created these
see-through transparent
public toilets is because there has been
this
like stigma or whatever i don't know
call it stigma but like this
idea that public restrooms are just so
disgusting and scary and dark and gross
and ill and nobody wants to use them so
they'd rather their use
toilets i haven't seen an american one
because all the ones in japan are nice
as well
yeah their idea of growth is like our
idea of clean
because we'll go with my mom's like that
bathroom's disgusting and i'm like i'll
[ __ ] in it all day
yeah have you seen the am pm yeah oh my
god
they don't have cocka smudged on the
sink
they don't have pee pee on the floor and
graffiti all over and
and i feel like i don't know and a whole
roll of toilet paper in the toilet bowl
yeah why
why are people such [ __ ] things that
i've witnessed here i'm just like
do you [ __ ] at like that at home there's
like 180 gangs etched into the wall
i'm like they're not even this many
gangs
[Laughter]
yeah did all the gangs of america come
to that 1am pm in the middle of the
mojave desert
and they're all trying to fight for red
yeah well
anyway back to this so the reason why
they created it is so
you can see before you even enter before
you pay
to use the public toilet that it is very
clean
and sanitized and everything is
beautiful and then people are like wait
i'm not gonna take a [ __ ] while other
people are looking at me taking a [ __ ]
well you don't have to worry about that
because it gets
opaque after right here there we go as
soon as it's occupied
the glass turns pink damn
so they'll still see you but you're just
blurry
yeah they know if you're wanting no
bathroom sex happening there
probably not unless they were trying to
get b-boy type of sex
it's not that hard to find a bathroom in
japan though
i think it's funny because it's you can
there's even glass between the rooms
so you're like hey you're shin i'm [ __ ]
and like you
you know when someone else is doing
something to the wall
i feel you i know what you're doing and
i'm doing like at the airport you know
like at the airport i sit in the stall
and i'm taking a dump
and then the minute i hear the person's
belt buckle loosening up i'm like
this guy's about to sit down too you
feel the bond i look over
he sits down i see the shoes turn the
other way
and then he starts making all kinds of
crazy ass noises
oh he's having a rough one
he's just shooting out of his butt
you're so empathetic when that happens
because when that happens to me and i'm
in the other one i'm like ah here we go
he's ruining my [ __ ] experience over
here i do go
please don't splash on my shoes splish
splash i was taking it
when i went to the office you could hear
when all your co-workers were [ __ ]
from the outside or when you're no when
you're in their european or whatever you
hear your co-workers [ __ ] and then
you see them go to the sink and
they're like morning and you're just
like i just saw you yeah
you're a monster actually did you have
the cubicle that was right next to the
toilet
no no no if i was in if i was in the
bathroom oh
it's also more telling for guys because
you guys have stalls and you only go in
there to take a [ __ ] because for girls
it's like we could be peeing or
taking a [ __ ] well some guys go in there
for some reason and pee i don't know i
don't like them
i don't like those guys because we are
dirty
and they they tend to pee on the seat
yeah why is it that they can't lift a
damn
seat and they have pee all over the seat
they don't want to probably touch
the seat but i use my i kick it with my
shoe yeah that's what i do
i just take the toilet paper you can do
that i just use that
like that i just don't know what is it
about
our bathrooms that make people want to
piss all over the chair and everything
because it's already pissed on it's like
i might as well join in
i think it's something are we missing a
class in first grade or something
here like bathroom etiquette right yeah
because when i go to people's homes
their bathrooms are not cocked all over
so i'm like
who are the people doing this well some
people sometimes like
they have like pee and stuff because
some people just don't aim really well
yeah that that makes sense there's like
a little bit of drizzle but i never see
it
on the seat like i see it at a public
restroom
and if people are watching this right
now they're going wow they talk about
this a lot it's because it happens
everywhere well i think too out here we
have a lot of like
[ __ ] crackheads druggies homeless
people that just don't give a [ __ ] so i
think they start the trend and then the
dicks and the [ __ ] and the [ __ ] i
think also we don't have that community
aspect here so it's like oh i'm [ __ ]
it up like
i don't care about you guys i care about
myself so if i p.i i'm not going to see
it again
yeah like in other countries i don't see
people like oh can i use a restroom
and they give you a key that's like
attached to a fire hydrant
because they know you're gonna [ __ ]
take this [ __ ] home in other countries
they're like
oh yeah here or just what's the biggest
attachment you've seen to a key
i think i've had like a whole spatula
i've never had that
i've had a [ __ ] rim like a hubcap
like a
hubcap i've never had something that big
i can't see why though
because i actually took the uh
restaurant
so you are the culprit you know why it's
because i would i would do that too
because i put things in my pocket and i
forget i mean what are you gonna we're
gonna put it like after you
open the door you put in your pocket you
pee wash your hands and then you leave
right
thank god it was our own spot junebe
because you know i don't know but if it
was somewhere else you know imagine if i
stole a
i don't know like taco bell's restroom
key but that's why they need a [ __ ]
hubcap attachment yeah because then you
don't miss it
yeah i hope you don't because i put it
on the sink first like that and then i
go yeah
because it'll fit in your pocket or
you'll notice that i want to put it in
there if i could yep
maybe it has something to do with the
american stress we're always on the go
because other countries i don't really
more stressed in japan they're [ __ ]
running
everywhere they die from over working
but they also have self-awareness so
they go fun
be a good bathroom user return the key
so they're constantly like governing i
think
we're just we're just oblivious and
we're just doing all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
and we forget to take
i think that people if they don't own it
or have a stake in why
it should be cleaned yeah they don't
give a [ __ ] yeah that's what
that's american style yeah that's
american stuff i know i think we have
the mentality of someone's paid to do
this
so why should i do it versus
like back when you're talking about
doing something yeah so far because then
you're like oh yeah
i'm providing i don't know the census
conversation nelson
they don't know in context he's been
saying that multiple videos so we're
we're beginning to connect the dots and
we're thinking that it just comes from
people like joe
i am guilty of peeing all over the
toilet
as a kid do you also scream out that
statement i'm providing jobs
but i never thought that it was because
a janitor would clean it up
i just didn't know where it went after
because the next day i came to school
and it was cleaned up
right like and then when you're a kid
you do stupid [ __ ]
because it's funny true that's why every
time i see
bathrooms all [ __ ] up like that was
like tatted up or like with the edge
etching yeah
i always think it's like a 13 year old
wannabe gangbanger i just imagine joe
leaving the bathroom as a
janitor goes in and he like winks at
them and he's like you're welcome
[Laughter]
your work's not going to be boring today
i've been to a lot of public restrooms
i've never seen a sick gangbanger
walking out and being like yeah i just
tagged that [ __ ]
like so i think i think you're on to
something it might be a kid
yeah most likely just a little yeah
because i get it as a kid
you pee on things you're not supposed to
pee on there
there's a pee obsession stage i think
some boys go through
you pee on walls you pee on floors you
pee everywhere because it's funny
it's wrong but i was one of those idiots
but then when you become an adult and
you need to take a [ __ ] and there's piss
everywhere you're going
why did i do that i did that to somebody
else maybe it's territorial
like like gang stuff you're marking your
territory oh when you said walls you
meant the walls of the bathroom
everywhere my friends walls
i remember the kids who thought that was
funny in elementary school all over the
place
we did a whole skit about like pissing
on each other and [ __ ] and like
piss wars i couldn't wait so i could
like pee
on a wall and make a circle you make a
circle on the wall
like draw a circle with my pee oh wow
what i hope is really going on
is like the reason why there's all these
etchings in the bathroom is that
they're not kids and gangs have meetings
and they're like we need to hit all the
public restrooms
why aren't we hitting all this that's
their marketing strategy yeah right
that's what i hope is going what i'd
like to think is that they have more of
a joe mentality and they're like
okay guys janitors are losing their
jobs what can we do to help
okay because we got to give back as a
gang you know we steal but we're
just like an entire task force just for
the graffiti and stuff so
that's why they're like weak let's hit
up all the bathrooms and the rest stops
let's etch them and and and they'll be
there they'll have a job forever you
know how long it takes
have you guys ever seen a mirror that's
so etched in
it looks like aluminum foil yeah and you
can't even see the reflection
i'm like damn and then that's when they
revert to like that sheet
and i'm like why the [ __ ] even put a
[ __ ] sheet like you can't even see
it's not gonna work well i gotta just
the hieroglyphics man
in the future aliens are gonna study
this [ __ ] and they're gonna be like all
right
humans were dumb as [ __ ] they were uh
cycle repeats itself yeah imagine
digging this up and trying to look at it
and analyze it the way we do
hieroglyphics
though it's like [ __ ] [ __ ] and balls
on the on the wall
like of a of an amp and bathroom mirror
and it's just like what were they like
what did the society try to say yeah
where is this and then some ancient
aliens guy is gonna come and say you
know what
that lines up with these stars and they
were trying to communicate
or or they didn't have the technology to
pull this off they needed help
they needed help it couldn't have done
it alone alien that kind of [ __ ] and
ball architecture
somebody had to teach them how to do
this
with the technology we have today we
wouldn't be able to do it
i can't do it right now i know dude
imagine that guy in the like trying to
actually
make like in the mirror he's trying to
actually make a [ __ ] ball he's like see
we can't do it we don't have the tools
with this simple ballpoint pen there's
no way we could have done this but with
[Music]
lasers
[Music]
you